if you can create from wholeness
instead of
separation or lack
you can produce greater effects
on the nature of reality by placing into
your imagination what you want and
assuming the feeling of that wish is
already fulfilled you go through your
life feeling that when enough of us do
that we will we will transform this
planet i'm telling you it can be done
the vibration that the mind and body are
in is going to dictate what you attract
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you do you have michael jordan
level talent at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how you can manifest what you want out
of life
enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one create from wholeness with dr joe
dispenza it's science that demystifies
the mystical
and if you can combine a little quantum
physics with a little neuroscience with
neuroendocrinology with
psychoneuroimmunology the mind-body
connection epigenetics all of those
sciences point the finger at possibility
and
if you talk about religion if you talk
about culture if you talk about
tradition even spirituality i noticed
that you divide an audience
but science in a sense creates community
so people come
for all kinds of reasons and what i've
learned in the last year or so is that
what people really want is wholeness
because when we want something we're in
separation or in lack right
and so when we started
experimenting with doing different
scientific measurements
one of the things we started to notice
is that when a person
somehow connects
to something greater
and that has a influence on their
nervous system
the side effect is that they feel so
whole
so rejuvenated in that moment so blessed
by life
in that moment from an inner experience
that it's impossible for them to want i
mean how can you want
when you feel whole right and so when we
started looking at heart coherence and
we saw this
tremendous
changes in in the uh people's ability to
be able to sustain
a state of mind a feeling in their heart
for an extended period of time
we have data to show you could be sick
and do that you could be a vegetarian
and do that you could be a carnivore and
do that you could be rich you could be
poor and it doesn't if you're skinny
overweight doesn't matter once you learn
that skill of self-regulation
and being able to experience a greater
level of wholeness
that if you can create from wholeness
instead of
separation or lack you can produce
greater effects
on the nature of reality so
we came from singularity and in when
your oneness or when your source
there's no separation between cause and
effect your thoughts create experiences
when you're in oneness we journey down
the density and now we're really
separate from source
and so the
what what happens between cause and
effect is called time
so we're here now
to prove to ourselves that the divine
lives in us
so why not practice
shortening
time
or the interval between cause the
thought and the effect the experience
and when you start seeing something
appear in your life as a result of you
at cause
you start getting more kind
more caring more loving more conscious
more present because you feel more whole
rule number two choose your frequency
with bob proctor there's a primary law
called the law of vibration
the law of vibration decrees that
everything in this universe moves
nothing rests
the body in a coffin is moving uh
probably you're probably thinking this
guy's smoking something like if the body
in a coffin wasn't moving how would it
ever change to dust
it's always moving it's always vibrating
everything vibrates we live in an ocean
of motion take a microscope and look at
a solid wall
it's not solid it only appears to be
solid or perception problem there you'll
see the wall moving right in front of
your eyes there's a particle of energy
and they're dancing right before your
eyes that's a lot of vibration the law
of vibration decrees everything moves
nothing rests we literally live in a
notion of motion now this physical
instrument we're living in we call our
body is a molecular structure and it's
in a very high speed of vibration
our brain is an electronic switching
station
when we activate brain cells we alter
the vibration in different parts of the
body i could not move my hand up and
down or my arm up and down without first
giving a message to my brain to do that
well the brain
activates cells in the body it sets up a
vibration in the body
the vibration that the mind and body are
in is going to dictate what you attract
because when you put yourself in a
vibration what you're really doing is
put yourself on a specific frequency
that's what you do when you set a goal
most people set a goal and then wait for
it to happen and never going to happen
you've got to assume that it's already
happened you've got a picture of it in
your mind mentally it's already happened
it's happened because i've got the idea
in my conscious mind if i didn't have
the idea of my conscious mind i couldn't
talk to you about it the very fact i can
talk to you about it means that i've
already got it
then i've got to get emotionally
involved in it
i'm already emotionally involved in the
goal that i've got i've got it
intellectually i've got it emotionally
it's only a period of time till it moves
into form how does it move into form
well you attract whatever is required
for it to move into form you attract all
the energy that's necessary to produce
the physical result how do you do that
you do that by intellectually
emotionally staying in the vibration
of the good that you desire you see it
already in the present tense so that
keeps you on the frequency
and that frequency then dictates what
you're going to attract you can only
attract to you what's in harmonious
vibration with you
now if you're holding an image that you
can't get something you're on a
vibration you're not going to get it but
if you can see yourself with it you know
it's coming to you you know it you know
it's only a period of time you're not
quite sure what the time is but you know
it's a period of time and bang that
thing's going to manifest in your life
you have controlled the vibration that
you're in
the vibration then called the frequency
you put yourself in the frequency that
you good your desires on let's suppose i
want to have a lot of money we're just
talking about money now this is a lot of
money relative to let's say
this there's one 100 here's 10 100 100.
so one's a lot relative to the other
neither one is a lot it just is
if i want to attract a lot of my i got
to see myself with a lot of money i got
to mentally accept i've already got it i
don't let my bank account dictate that
i choose that
so choosing myself to see myself with
the good i already desire i'm on that
frequency now the trick is to stay on
that frequency
most people look at the results and they
let the results dictate the frequency
they're on that's why they keep getting
the same results they have the image in
their mind they're already reached the
goal they want they're already
successful and somebody else comes along
and say well you haven't got those
results
in my mind i have but they're not
looking in my mind they're looking at my
present results and then pretty soon i
start listening to them i think god
they're right i look at my results i
haven't got it
do you see why we keep getting this poor
results
you've got to see yourself with the good
you desire you've got to hold that image
in your mind you've got to know it's
going to come and that will attract
everything that's necessary see nothing
is created or destroyed everything's
already here if done in one frequency
certainly in another or not in one state
certainly in another we've got to get on
the frequency of the good that we desire
rule number three place it in your
imagination with dr wayne dyer the basic
thing that neville taught me and a lot
of this is from the teachings of neville
uh neville goddard who died in the 1970s
he
he basically said that um all of us have
within us this
amazing capacity to manifest and attract
anything that we want into our life so
how we call it what what words that we
use we have to be able to say um you
know in the secret they say you you get
what you want you know and what is
missing and what neville said and what
has come to me and what i got from the i
am discourses and what i get from the
new testament which i read before i did
it is that you you say
i will attract into my life what i am
not what i want
and i am capable of attracting all
things that
that the source is capable of attracting
so
that's the difference it's like you get
what you are rather than what you want
so you want to become
you can't go around and ask these divine
beings
you know angels whatever you want to
call them who are right here all the
time
you can't you can't ask them to help me
out you have to you have to become like
they are
that when you're when you become angelic
when you become a divine being yourself
when you are giving when you are serving
when you are in that place they will
come to you that's what happened to you
in india you then begin to see yourself
in everything that's what the tao de
ching teaches as well they call it your
original nature your original nature is
reverence for all of life gentleness
kindness and service towards others
that's lao tzu 500 years before the
birth of christ saying that's our
original nature yes reverence for all of
life gentleness kindness service towards
other giving offering serving and when
you get to that place where you no
longer have any judgment within you
towards any of god's children that means
no condemnation no criticism no judgment
towards anyone even the osama bin laden
and if enough of us get this message
over if enough of us get in that's just
what my mission is is just to teach
people that you are love you are divine
put that into your imagination i am i am
well i am happy i am content i am
fulfilled even if your senses tell you
that you're depressed one of your people
that called me when we did a
pre-interview on here said well if i if
i'm feeling depressed i'm supposed to
fool myself and say i am feeling well
even you can't choose another thought
that's what i have absolutely and it's
like you don't say i am depressed
because if you say i am depressed you
connect with depression and the
universal source god whatever you want
to call it will align in such a way to
offer you whatever it is
yeah here's some more depression i am
unhappy i am depressed i am so by
placing into your imagination what you
want and assuming the feeling of that
wish is already fulfilled you go through
your life feeling that when enough of us
do that we will we will transform this
planet i'm telling you it can be done
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four have a vision
with marissa peer
percent of you who use a vision book or
a vision board say
it changed me
i've told you about my vision board i
had it above my bed i wanted to get
married i wanted to go to africa and
here's a picture of my wedding was such
a here's a picture of me in africa
holding a lion that had been raised from
a cub with a family and it it lived
there and it was amazing but i made
these come true i had that vision in my
mind i held that vision i'm
getting married i'm going on safari
and you're never given a vision without
an idea of making it real because what
you want wants you
what you are moving towards is moving
towards you have a vision or a dream or
a wish inside you
get it out of you
put it on paper look at it touch it
read it then you are making it real when
you can look at your vision right all
over your vision
write on it change it mix it up it's not
a dream
you're making it real your potential
expands as you move towards it this will
expand your potential
when you move your mind to a new
dimension it never moves back
never right i wish i dream right i am i
do i can i will i always
i always exercise i can
fit exercise into my life i am
a fit person
i always pick healthy food i can find
healthy food wherever i go i'm the kind
of person that makes eating well a
master priority i can i do i am i always
inspire your mind turn it on with
exciting words turn it on with exciting
images so here's
a vision folder the other thing about
this vision book is it makes you
accountable as you look every day at the
pictures of someone doing yoga
or eating fruit you think well
i better stop looking at that and start
doing it every day as you look at
pictures somebody working from home
socializing looking after their body
horse riding
hiking
making salads as you look at it enough
you become inspired
to take action it motivates you it
inspires you it fills up your mind with
what you want
and it fills you up with a desire a
passion
it motivates you conditions you programs
you compels you to go after what you
want
it holds you accountable
and it's so easy
so don't make it perfect rule number
five meet the vibration with oprah
winfrey i am a powerful manifesto you
have to meet the vibration you can't be
above or below it it's just what i was
talking about negative energy
positive energy in order to draw the
thing to you that you want to come you
can't want it so much that you fear that
you won't get it you have to want it so
in order for me to be on your vision
board you must have put it there and
then you let it go yes and then you
weren't thinking about it every day
every day every day because you can't it
doesn't come to you that way you have to
do it and then you have to put it and
then you have to meet that vibration you
prepare yourself to be there and ready
when it shows up and you were julie said
you were there rule number six be
grateful with lewis howes if you're
caught and thinking negatively about the
world and about yourself this is so
important
what would change inside of you if you
looked around
and you wrote down five things that
you're grateful for about the world now
this for me
is part of the secret to the law of
attraction it's the foundation is
gratitude it's your way of being must be
grateful in order to attract new things
there's so many things in my life that i
should not have attracted
because i didn't have the skills because
i didn't have the tools because i didn't
have the education because i didn't have
the money because i didn't have the
resources
so many things that i shouldn't have
attracted but because i had the
foundation of gratitude
passion joy curiosity those things
started to come to me and they can come
to you as well if you come from that
place of gratitude as your foundation
so you want to think about what are
these things that are important to me in
my life you know it can be simple things
it could be like this cup of coffee that
i have right now it can be that i have a
roof over my head that i've got quality
friends that i'm healthy
you know that i'm walking in nature
today it doesn't have to be
some grandiose thing that's happened to
you to be grateful for i'm so grateful
for these little present moments
with people that i care about to spend
an hour on the beach to go for a walk
with a friend to have a good
conversation with someone and talk about
something that i'm going through for me
that's just as meaningful
the moments in between the big moments
are just as meaningful so write down
these things or think about these things
this is something i embed in my daily
life when i wake up i think about what
i'm grateful for when i go to sleep i i
think about and reflect on the things
i'm grateful for from that day and it's
just my way of being for as much as i
can now i'm not perfect i make mistakes
and there's some times i'm negative but
it's something that i try to really
focus on as much as possible so instead
of saying that you're not enough
that you don't deserve success what if
you looked in the mirror on a daily
basis i dare you to look in the mirror
on a daily basis and say i am enough and
i do deserve
the results that i want to create in my
life because i show up because i'm
consistent because i work hard because i
care about my work
if you looked in the mirror and you did
this consistently for 30 days and you
actually
use the word action in attraction and
you put it into practice on a daily
basis towards that growth
i'd be amazed to see what you attract
and what you manifest in your life and
rule number seven the last one before
some very special bonus clips is be
clear with gabby bernstein
manifesting is acquiring the experience
of what it is that you want to feel and
being and living and believing in that
experience and then allowing that
experience to come into form sometimes
we manifest things far beyond our
wildest dreams so sometimes if we have a
vision of something it happens in a far
greater way so we want to stay open yep
so we can say i want that macbook air
but maybe we get that macbook air that's
a little bit bigger than we thought yeah
or maybe it comes with an extra little
gift yeah but allowing ourselves to be
open this or something more manifesting
is very creative it is the process of
using your power energy and being in
that presence of your high-powered
energy and allowing that energy to
co-create with the energy that's around
you so you're vibrating at a high
frequency i'm vibrating at high
frequency we've done a lot of work we've
cleaned up a lot of our own crap we
believe in ourselves today and that that
energy of believing in ourselves has
attracted us together today and brought
us into the space where we together are
co-creating and teaching if i hadn't
cleaned up my side of the street and if
i didn't believe in myself the way i do
i would never have manifested being on
marietv miracles occur naturally and
when they're not occurring something has
gone wrong
that's interesting it's a good one right
so what happens is that that
synchronicity that flow that effortless
action that just sort of allowing oh i
was thinking about that and it just
showed up that's how life is supposed to
be
we get in the way our negative belief
systems our fears our anxiety our our
anger towards the past that future
tripping and projecting all of that
energy gets in the way of allowing all
of the miracles to occur naturally the
first type of manifestation is to get
very very clear and you know if we're
not clear about what we desire then we
can call in some really funky stuff you
must be clear because if you are unclear
you'll start to call in some things that
are not really what you want you'll be
confused uh the other piece is that once
you're clear you can also then get clear
about all the ways that you don't
believe all of the limiting beliefs all
the negativity that might be blocking it
most people never manifest their ideas
because you don't trust your ideas that
bold idea that came to you that made
sense to you in the moment the next day
feels too bold too crazy too insane to
not for someone like you i believe that
the decisions that come to you when
you're feeling bold are actually the
right ones for you and you have to take
immediate action on because otherwise
your head gets in the way and talks you
down from doing the things that you
should be doing so right now i'm in the
process of looking for a creative
director for my business someone to look
at all my content suggest ways to make
it better to to
be focused on the branding and
opportunities for me
and this was a suggestion from mark
drager friend of the channel a long time
personal friend of mine as well he
helped film my very first video he's the
reason why i did top 10 moves to success
long story with mark and he said evan
you need a creative director for your
business creative director or brand
manager or ceo somebody to be in charge
of all the creative decisions and
getting me out on the stages that they
need to be out on
so how do we make these videos better
that's that person's role and so in my
head
when he first said it i'm a little
afraid i'm scared like
how do i find this person i need to vibe
well with them i don't i can't just
bring anybody into that role i'm a
pretty weird duck and so this has to be
a good you know long-term fit for me how
much is this person gonna cost how do i
fit into my cost structure right now
with my business how are we going to
deal with conflicts it's all of the
negativity all of the things that
are reasons why it's not going to work
and so in setting to focus on this is a
bold idea and i need to at least explore
it i need to try it i need to play it
out maybe it works maybe it doesn't but
teaching yourself teaching myself that i
do bold things i do scary things i do
difficult things and being scared is not
a good enough reason for not to take
action and so those ideas that come to
you trust that they came to you for a
reason
if it came to you and you're thinking
about it and you feel both like man i
would love to go off and do that the
best thing you can do is just start
going off and doing that
because what's going to happen is you're
going to plan plan plan plan plan you're
going to spend all your best energies
just stuck in planning mode instead of
actually going out and taking action
you're going to tell your friends about
it they're going to tell you it's a
stupid idea you're going to sleep on it
you're going to wake up and tell
yourself it's a stupid idea and then
what happens is no momentum the biggest
thing that is missing from your life
is momentum
nina's happy you know smiling she's next
to me filming that's always missing
you're a genius you have great ideas
great genius amazing ideas you're just
missing momentum
because once you get the idea you sit on
it and then you tell yourself why you
can't do it instead of going off and
proving to yourself that you can so how
do you find the ideas and then how do
you take action on them i'm going to
give you a three-step process step
number one is go for a walk have a
shower do whatever the thing is that
makes you feel
energized creative and in the zone right
if you're constantly just in front of
your phone and stressed out all day long
you're not gonna come up with creative
ideas so where do you get creative ideas
i get creative ideas when i'm driving i
get creative ideas when i'm in the
shower i get creative ideas when i'm
walking i don't really meditate so i
don't get ideas when i'm doing that but
it's it's time when there's nothing
scheduled
and so do you have enough time during
your week or during your day that is
open that you allow yourself to think
and be creative
for a lot of people watching this you
probably do you probably have some
moments in your calendar that are
dedicated to at least having a shower
hopefully hopefully you have showers on
a regular basis right so you're coming
up with ideas right so whatever that
thing is that lets you come with ideas
do more of it right if you get great
ideas in the shower
maybe instead of a five minute shower
take a 15 minute shower maybe you get
some more ideas coming to you right you
want to you want to spend more time
doing the work that generates creativity
for you that's step number one step
number two is don't judge the ideas that
come to you this is where so many people
fall down you get an idea and then you
judge it and you say i can't do that i'm
not good enough i don't have the money i
know the connections i didn't go to
school for that i'm not tall enough i'm
not pretty enough i'm not smart enough
whatever people like me don't do this
thing all these ideas why you can't win
you're telling yourself why you can't
win before you even started
don't judge the idea trust that the idea
came to you for a reason so if i'm
thinking about somebody
in the shower somebody that maybe i met
yesterday or somebody that i haven't
talked to in three years
why am i thinking about that person uh i
don't know
italians have this expression they go
book means i don't know
so i trust that idea came for a reason
that idea is flowing through me for a
reason and i got to do something about
it and so whenever i'm thinking about
somebody in the shower the next thing is
i get out of the shower and i'll email
that person right away and i'll always
make it awkward and say hey i was
thinking about you in the shower today
and then tell them what the story was
and it's never backfired on me
it's never backfired on me
sometimes it leads to some great
opportunity and sometimes it goes
nowhere but you get the idea you do
something get the idea you do something
stop judging the idea stop telling
yourself why you can't do it and then
step number three is take immediate
action and build momentum again the
biggest thing that you're just missing
is momentum you're a genius you're an
amazing entrepreneur you've got tons of
potential sarah blakely had this idea to
create spanx and it made her billionaire
when everybody thought she was crazy
right i'm sure you have ideas like that
too what's the difference between you
and her momentum
she did more she started she took the
nose she took the rejection she took the
fears and she said i'm gonna give it my
shot
you need to build immediate momentum as
soon as you get that idea whether it's
in the shower on the walk on the drive
whatever it is as soon as you get that
you're not allowed to leave that moment
that moment of courage i'm going to bold
this a moment of feeling unstoppable
that moment of like i can do this when
you're feeling that moment you're not
allowed to leave it without having done
something
immediate action every single time and
sometimes that leads to something great
and maybe the momentum falls off the
next day that's okay but in the moment
you have to take immediate action no
more excuses stop letting yourself off
the hook stop telling yourself that you
suck and you can't do it and go show
yourself that you can i once heard a
definition of health that made a lot of
sense to me
good health it said
is having no fatigue
having a good appetite
going to sleep and awakening easily
having a good memory
having good humor
and having precision in thought and
action
not being clutzy
being honest
humble
grateful and loving
how healthy are you
i do not heal anyone
the work i do is to help people
understand how their own mental patterns
are constantly creating their own life
experiences
all of them
the good experiences
and the so-called bad experiences
and also
how these same mental patterns
are contributing to the ease
and dis-ease
in their bodies
we do not want to be ill
and yet we need every disease we have
it is the body's way of telling us
that we have a false idea in
consciousness
our body is telling us
we are on the wrong track
and need to change the way we think
every illness
is a lesson
for us to learn
please do not just complain i want to
get rid of this condition
it will not create the healing you want
nor will you learn the lesson you need
to learn
this is not a time for condemnation
or for creating more guilt
we are just looking at what needs to be
released
this is a time for healing
for making our lives and our bodies
whole
i know
you have within you all that you need to
accomplish
this
once we begin to understand this process
we are able to take conscious control
of the changes we wish to make in our
lives
this is a very exciting process
and becomes one of the most important
adventures in our lives
i believe
there is a center of wisdom within each
one of us and when we are ready to make
positive changes in our lives
we attract whatever we need to help us
something inside of you has shifted
and the healing process has already
begun
you might even say that to yourself now
i have already begun
the healing process
the body like everything else in life
is a mirror of our inner thoughts and
beliefs
the body is always talking to us if we
will only take the time to listen
every cell
responds to every single thought you
think
and every word you speak
continuous modes of thinking and
speaking produce body behaviors and
postures and eases or dis-eases
the person who has a permanently
scowling face
did not produce that by having joyous
loving thoughts
older people's faces and bodies
show so clearly a lifetime of inner
dialogue
how will you look when you are elderly
you see it is my belief that it is our
birthright to be totally healthy and
totally fulfilled
in every area of our lives take a nice
deep breath
and if possible
allow yourself to be in a comfortable
position
just let these ideas wash over you
only those ideas that are right for you
will be accepted by you
it doesn't matter whether you understand
them all or not
or if they make sense to you right now
your subconscious mind will hear and
record whatever you
need i believe that all illness is
self-created
not that we say i want to have this
illness
but we create a mental atmosphere where
this dis-ease can grow and flourish
our internal mental dialogue
reacts in every cell
in the body
i heard a physician say recently
if the surgeon operates on a patient
without doing something to help them
change the cause of the disease
then all the doctor is doing is
prolonging the life of the patient
until the patient can create another
dis-ease
you see we need to do more than just
treat the symptom
we need to eliminate the cause of the
dis-ease
and for that we need to go within
ourselves where the process of illness
began
it is my belief that we are each
responsible for every experience in our
lives
the best and the worst
we all create our experiences by the
thoughts we think and the words we speak
the universe totally supports our
internal dialogue
our subconscious mind accepts as truth
whatever we choose to believe
you can say it either way
they both mean that what i believe about
myself and about life becomes true for
me
what you choose to think about yourself
and about life becomes true for you
[Music]
if you want to learn the law of
attraction hack with dr joe dispenza
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there when i get my new
car i get my new house i get my new
relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great now that
well then they're back to the program
waiting for it to happen